hello my friends looks like weird
positions let the shimmer food alright
so first things first we gotta find a
slip here's hot who's hot in the media
today Robert Downey jr. and we're nor in
I would some Gwenyth Paltrow
when it
hmm
number this one
this was a little cute when I heard her
trying to hide I can't hide from
Photoshop okay you can't hide I'm
Ignacio
um now what you what you can hide from
okay I was just shirt gynecology Jesus
what most terrifying thing a wall hmm
freakin pogs man all right yes idea who
we use behind let's take a bunch of
[ __ ] high def pictures wow this took
so confused
probably a natural let's face it plastic
surgery blue eyes okay so let's let's
just try and make it more I don't know
earthly and get some realize in there
and nothing is probably as real and
legitimate as a puck okay so let's get
some some real eyes on her
Oh guys this is going to be this is
going to be divine i feel i mean i would
say i always feel a little weird about
this because i essentially feel like
we're doing God's work here and I don't
know it just seems like whom I to play
God yeah but we all buy photoshop so I
guess is us Oh Gweneth oh go on it miss
pepper potts he knew you he knew this
would happen when you sign up for Miss
Pepperpot says I'm and love interest in
the classic iron man so let's not let's
let's not play victim here okay I just I
relate the black accent of the pugs I
know some people just go straight for
the eyeballs but I actually like that
you know now you want to be able to tell
the pawn guys okay you don't want to
just what is that is that like a bug on
her face now okay this is a property oh
god it looks like she's wearing a
gigantic disgusting I patch the evil
villain but we're not here to make vote
evo okay actually we should continue to
do this
she losing a cyborg
youtube cheese actually looking dream
I'm not gonna live she's looking pretty
evil it's amazing what one pug I could
do to someone especially a B plus a
minus the sacker but looking great so
far I'd say looking divine holy [ __ ]
were you through big normal size okay
you're not trying to scare anyone I'm
not trying to frighten the kids here
we're just trying to be you know
realists Oh chef Wade still owes you big
innit
oh my god that now makes it so scary I
think it's a dead stare that's probably
most horrifying of all this let's have
her oh my god let's meet the other one
which is hiding from it's like a messy
divorce you know
done
beautiful stunning
stunning stunning stunning I literally
cannot say actually how beautiful this
is it was a little speech beldar saying
let's be hysterical and put it in comic
sans oh my god hilarious well I'm so
funny all right this looks freaking
amazing okay God
like part of on to cry but also part of
you want to like Tamara elbows out and
rub them against the screen because
they're so freaking great this image of
phenomenal for my eyes you're gonna do
another one all right let's just go to a
real classic celebs eating I like how
there's like so many watch from Pollitz
popper lies kind of suggested terms I
like these images included don't content
even though it's obvious that they're
just like people eating sandwiches oh my
god no wonder they freaking bandit um Oh
video what's it over there no wonder you
know what let's just let's put this on
moderate safe search so we don't get any
like insanely graphic porn that's our
fine
oh this is amazing heidi klum you are
mcdonald's salad about eating champion
now let's put in there possibly the only
thing that fits a meerkat I say that's
because it it obviously happens to me
like the exact proportion of the
mcdonalds bracket so that's what we're
going to do okay
tetas beautiful Heidi Klum is beautiful
put it back round this like a volcano
background
you
yes yes all right there we have it today
celebs made mortal ok loves me more well
you guys enjoyed this this session if
you guys enjoyed really watching
celebrities being normal human beings
like I did please hit subscribe button
and like it and there'll be more you can
see well